hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to in two
minutes now at 2015 hasn't been the most
abundant year for sci-fi we've ever had
it's almost as if the movie studios
publishers and TV execs or Star Wars
just looming on the horizon and quietly
decided to bow out this year but saying
that there have been a few sci-fi gems
in 2015 and there are a couple more just
around the corner 2015 has been quite AI
heavy the joint US and UK venture humans
based on a popular Swedish drama
explores a world where the must-have
accessory is a highly advanced robotic
servant known as a synth think
bicentennial man but a lot less
heartwarming and with a lot more
questions about robot ethics enslaved
dread and 28 days later writer Alex
Collins directorial debut ex machina was
a slick and stylish take on the
well-worn sci-fi trope of AI the film's
intellectual take on the subject matter
is bound to make you fear Google even
more than you already do and speaking of
AI there were no strings on age of
Ultron yes the action rod may not have
been as entertaining as the original
superhero ensemble but it has set up the
marvel cinematic universe as third phase
quite nicely with its mid-credits teased
for infinity war an honorable mention
here of course as well for ant-man while
it may be didn't hit the lofty
box-office highs of previous Marvel
movies it didn't take itself too
seriously and was a genuinely funny
sci-fi action movie in space no one can
hear you scream especially when they
accidentally leave you behind on Mars
coming out next month is the movie
adaptation of Andy Weir's best-selling
novel the Martian featuring none other
than yeah Jamie as the stranded botanist
who uses his sprouting smarts to survive
the scares of the Red Planet it's been a
light year for safe x games but still to
come week with the crown prince of TV
science fiction Nathan Fillion reprising
his role as buck in halo 5 Guardians
there's also a drift a first-person game
about an astronaut lost and floating in
an abandoned Space Station think gravity
but with weezer providing the soundtrack
also left to come is sci-fi rom-com the
lobster where single people have 45 days
to find a romantic partner if they fail
they get turned into a
animal and let loose in the woods for
reasons you've gotta respect a movie
that's based on a line from friends see
he's her Lobster and finally honorable
mentions for the so bad it's good sci-fi
from 2015 try and keep fond memories of
the first two movies in your mind if you
choose to watch terminator genisys a
film which had its big plot twist ruined
in its own trailer and Jupiter ascending
it seems that no one can tell there were
ciao skis know anymore hence this
mishmash of flying boots werewolves and
bees are genetically designed to smell
royalty beads jobs not on board so there
we have it some of 2015's best I five it
isn't Star Wars or mad max but I'd cast
that more as post-apocalyptic anyway are
there any other glaring emissions be
sure to let me know in the comments
section below I'll come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lucy James games I'll see
you next time
you